Sora the text video model from open AI
is here and it appears to be exciting
people and worrying them in equal
measure there is something visceral
about actually seeing the rate of
progress in AI that hits different than
leaderboards or benchmarks and in just
the last 18 hours the technical report
for Sora has come out and more demos and
details have been released I'm going to
try to unpack what Sora is what it means
means and what comes next before getting
into any details though we just have to
admit that some of the demos are frankly
astonishing this one a tour of an art
gallery is jawdropping to me but that
doesn't mean we have to get completely
carried away with open ai's marketing
material that the model understands what
the user asks for and understands how
those things exist in the physical world
I don't even think the authors of Sora
would have signed off on that statement
and I know it might seem I'm being
pedantic but these kind of edge case
failures is what's held back
self-driving for a decade yes Sora has
been trained at an immense scale but I
wouldn't say that it understands the
world it has derived billions and
trillions of patterns from the world but
can't yet reason about those patterns
hence anomalies like the video you can
see and later on in the release notes
open AI says this the current model has
weaknesses it may struggle with
accurately simulating the physics of a
complex scene it doesn't quite get cause
and effect it also mixes up left and
right and objects appear spontaneously
and disappear for no reason it's a bit
like gp4 in that it's breathtaking and
intelligent but if you probe a bit too
closely Things Fall Apart a little bit
to be clear I am stunned by Sora just as
much as everyone else I just want it to
be put in a little bit of context that
being said if and when models crack
reasoning itself I will try to be among
the first to let you know it's time for
more details and Sora can generate
videos up to a full minute long up to
1080p it was trained on and can output
different aspect ratios and resolutions
and speaking of high resolution this
demo was amongst the most shocking it is
incredible just look at the consistent
Reflections in terms of how they made it
they say model and implementation
details are not included in this report
but later on they give hints in terms of
the papers they site in the appendices
almost all of them funnily enough come
from Google we have Vision Transformers
adaptable aspect ratio and resolution
Vision Transformers also from Google
Deep Mind and we saw that being
implemented with Sora and many other
papers from Facebook and Google were
cited that even LED one Google deep
minder to jokingly say this you're
welcome open AI I'll share my home
address in DM if you want to send us
flowers and chocolate by the way my
30second summary of how it's done would
be this this just think to yourself
about the task of predicting the next
word it's easy to imagine how you test
yourself you'd cover the next word make
prediction and check but how would you
do that for images or frames of a video
if all you did was cover the entire
image it would be pretty impossible to
guess say a video frame of a monkey
playing chess so how would you bridge
that Gap well as you can see below how
about adding some noise like a little
bit of cloudiness to the image you can
still see most of the image but now you
have to infer patches here and there
with say a text caption to help you out
that's more manageable right and now
it's just a matter of scale scale up the
number of images or frames of images
from a video that you train on
ultimately you could go from a highly
descriptive text caption to the full
image from scratch especially if the
captions are particularly descriptive as
they are for Sora now by the way all you
need to do is find a sugar daddy to
invest $13 billion into you and boom
you're there of course I'm being a
little bit factious it builds on years
of work including bu notable
contributors from open aai they
pioneered the autoc captioning of images
with highly descriptive language using
those synthetic captions massively
optimized the training process when I
mentioned scale by the way look at the
difference that more compute makes when
I say compute think of arrays of gpus in
a data somewhere in America when you
forx the compute you get this and if you
16 exit you get that more images more
training more compute better results now
I know what you're thinking just 100x
the compute there's definitely enough
data I did a back of the envelope
calculation that there are quadrillions
of frames just on YouTube definitely
easier to access if you're Google by the
way but I will caveat that as we've seen
with gp4 scale doesn't get you all the
way to reasoning so you'll still get
weird breaches of the laws of physics
until you get other Innovations thrown
in but then we get to something big that
I don't think enough people are are
talking about by training on video
You're inadvertently solving images an
image after all is just a single frame
of a video the images from Sora go up to
2K by 2K pixels and of course they could
be scaled up further with a tool like
magnific I tried that for this image and
honestly there was nothing I could see
that would tell me that this isn't just
a photo I'd almost ask the question of
whether this means that there won't be a
darly four because Sora supersedes it
take anim in an image and this example
is just incredible of this shba Inu dog
wearing a beret and black turtleneck
that's the image on the left and it
being animated on the right you can
imagine the business use cases of this
where people bring to life photos of
themselves friends and family or maybe
even deceased loved ones or how about
every page in what would be an otherwise
static children's book being animated on
demand you just click and then the
characters get animated honestly the
more I think about it the more I think
Sora is going to make open AI billions
and billions of dollars the number of
other companies and apps that it just
subsumes within it is innumerable I'll
come back to that point but meanwhile
here is a handful of other incredible
demos this is a movie trailer and notice
how Sora is picking quite Fast Cuts
obviously all automatically it gets that
a cinematic trailer is going to be
pretty Dynamic and fast-paced likewise
this is a single video generated by Sora
not a compilation and if you ignore some
text spelling issues it is
astonishing and here is another one that
I'm going to have to spend some time on
the implications of this feature alone
are astonishing all three videos that
you can see are going to end with the
exact same frame even that final frame
of the cable car crashing into that sign
was generated by Sora including the
minor misspelling at the top but just
think of the implications you could have
a photo with your friends and imagine a
hundred different ways that you could
have got there to that final photo or
maybe you have your own website and
every user gets a unique Voyage to your
landing page and of course when we scale
this up we could put the ending of a
movie in and Sora 2 or Sora 3 would
calculate all the different types of
movies that could have led to that point
you could have daily variations to your
favorite movie ending as as a side note
this also allows you to create these
funky Loops where the starting and
finishing frame are identical I could
just let this play for a few minutes
until people got really confused but I
won't do that to you and here is yet
another feature that I was truly bold
away with the video you can see on
screen was not generated by Sora and now
I'm going to switch to another video
which was also not generated by Sora but
what Sora can do is interpolate between
those videos to to come up with a unique
creation this time I'm not even going to
list the potential applications because
again they are innumerable what I will
do though is give you one more example
that I thought of when I saw this
another demo that open AI used was
mixing together this chameleon and this
funky looking bird I'm not sure it name
to create this wild mixture now we all
know that open AI are not going to allow
you to do this with human images but an
open-source version of Sora will be
following close behind so imagine
putting a video of of you and your
partner and creating this hybrid Freaky
video or maybe you and your pet now the
best results you're going to get from
Sora are inevitably when there's not as
much movement going on the less movement
the fewer problems with things like
object permanence mind you even when
there is quite a lot going on the
results can still be pretty incredible
look at how Sora handles object
permanence here with the dog fully
covered and then emerging looking
exactly the same likewise this video of
a man eating a burger because he's
moving in slow motion it's much more
High Fidelity aside from the Boker
effect it could almost be real and then
we get this gorgeous video where you
almost have to convince me it's from
Sora look at how the paint marks stay on
the page and then we get simulated
gaming where again if you ignore some of
the physics and the rule breaking the
visuals alone are just incredible
obviously they train Sora on thousands
of hours of Minecraft videos I mean look
how accurate some of the boxes are I bet
some of you watching this think I simply
replaced a SORA video with an actual
Minecraft video but no I didn't that has
been quite a few hype demos so time for
some anti-hype ones here is Sora clearly
not understanding the world around it
just like chat's understanding can
sometimes be paper thin so can sorus it
doesn't get the physics of the cup the
ice or the spill I can't forget to
mention though that you can also change
the style of a video here is the input
video presumably from a game now with
one prompt you can change the background
to being a
jungle or maybe you prefer to play the
game in the 1920s I mean you can see how
the wheels aren't moving properly but
the overall effect is
incredible well actually this time I
want to play the game underwater how
about that job done or maybe I'm high
and I want the game to look like a
rainbow or maybe I prefer the
oldfashioned days of pixel art I've
noticed a lot of people by the way
speculating where open AI got all the
data to train Sora I think many people
have forgotten that they did a deal back
in July with shutter stock in case you
don't know shutter stock has 32 million
stock videos and most of them are high
resolution they probably also used
millions of hours of video game frames
would be my guess one more thing you
might be wondering don't these worlds
just disappear the moment you move on to
the next prompt well with video 2 3D
that might not always be the case this
is from Luma Ai and imagine a world
generated at first by Sora then turned
into a universally sharable 3D landscape
that you can interact with effectively
you and your friends could inhabit a
world generated by Sora and yes
ultimately with scale you could generate
your own High Fidelity video game and
given that you can indefinitely extend
Clips I am sure many people will be
creating their own short movies perhaps
voiced by AI here's an 11 Labs voice
giving you a snippet of the caption to
this video an adorable happy otter
confidently stands on a surfboard
wearing a yellow life jacket riding
along turquoise tropical waters near
lush tropical Islands well how about
hooking Sora up to the Apple Vision Pro
or meta Quest especially for those who
can't travel that could be an incredible
way of exploring the world of course
being real here the most common use case
might be children using it to make
cartoons and play games but still that
counts as a valid use case to me but
underneath all of these use cases are
some serious points in a since deleted
tweet one openai employee said this we
are very intentionally not sharing it
widely yet the hope is that a mini
public demo kicks a social response into
gear I'm not really sure what social
response people are supposed to give
though however it's not responsible to
let people just Panic which is why I've
given the caveats I have throughout this
video I believe as with language and
self-driving that the edge cases will
still take a number of years to solve
that's at least my best guess but it
seems to me when reasoning is solved and
therefore even long videos actually make
sense a lot more jobs other than just
videographers might be under threat as
the creator of GitHub co-pilot put it if
openai is going to continue to eat AI
startups sector by sector they should go
public building the new economy where
only 500 people benefit is a dodgy
future and the founder of stability AI
tweeted out this image it does seem to
be the best of times and the worst of
times to be an AI startup you never know
when open aai or Google are going to
drop a model that massively changes and
affects your business it's not just Sora
whacking pea Labs Runway ML and maybe
mid Journey if you make the chips that
open AI uses they want to make them
instead I'm going to be doing a separate
video about all of that when you use the
chat PT app on a phone they want to make
the phone you're using you come up with
character Ai and open AI comes out with
the GPT store I bet open AI are even
cooking up an open world game with GPT
powered NPCs don't forget that they are
acquired Global illumination the makers
of this Minecraft clone if you make
agents we learned last week that open
aai want to create an agent that
operates your entire device again I've
got more on that coming soon or what
about if you're making a search engine
powered by a GPT model that's the case
of course with perplexity and I will be
interviewing the CEO and founder of
perplexity for AI insiders next week
insiders can submit questions and of
course do feel free to join on patreon
but fitting with the trend we learned
less than 48 hours ago that open AI is
developing a web search product I'm not
necessarily critiquing any of this but
you're starting to see the theme open AI
will have no quals about eating your
lunch and of course there's one more
implication that's a bit more longterm
two lead authors from Sora both
retweeted this video from Berkeley
you're seeing a humanoid transformer
robot trained with large scale
reinforcement learning in Sim imulation
and deployed to the real world zero shot
in other words it learned to move like
this by watching and acting in
simulations if you want to learn more
about learning from simulations do check
out my Eureka video and my interview
with Jim fan tldr better simulations
mean better robotics two final demos to
end this video with first a monkey
playing chess in a park this demo kind
of sums up Sora it looks gorgeous I was
astounded like everyone else however if
you look a bit closer the piece position
and board don't make any sense Sora
doesn't understand the world but it is
drawing upon billions and billions of
patterns and then there's this
obligatory comparison the Will Smith
spaghetti video and I wonder what source
they originally got some of the images
from you could say this was around
state-of-the-art just 11 months ago and
now here's Sora not perfect look at the
paws but honestly remarkable indeed I
would call Sora a milestone human
achievement but now I want to thank you
for watching this video all the way to
the end and know despite what many
people think it isn't generated by an AI
have a wonderful day